red sox starting pitcher eighth novelty
four and two
era of 462. one of the only the only
starter
that has not given up a home run he's
got some great stuff
that fastball has a little run on it
slight tail
plus heater and got jammed big time
little ground ball up the first base
line basket says throw it he does
and a home plate umpire had that as a
fair ball here comes
melvin out to argue this but that's out
number three at the moment
did that hit him yeah it looked like it
hit his forearm but you hear the bat
too obviously that is not a reviewable
play so you're relying on the other
umpires
one of the others and alex is pretty
steemed here
he's mad but to me it's a dead ball
he wants blakeney to stick to his call
right back
out is what that is that's exactly it
and a pop into right field renfro covers
that ground and for native aldi a quick
start gets him in order
sea bass chris bassett making his eighth
start of the season as well
you want to talk about slicing and dyson
oh chris bassett
got a four-star stretch of completing at
least
six innings punching out at least seven
third baseman's backed up and stroked
into right field coming on brown
back to tag up for dugo here he comes
the throw home won't get him and the red
sox have a one-nothing lead
and jd martinez has his 32nd run bad at
him
and it all started with the red sox of
course 2008.
the o2 waved at and missed down he goes
and struck him out
looked like he chased a hard cutter up
yes he did
nice ovation here for mitch moreland
mitchy two bags
played three and a half seasons here in
boston he had a nice career in boston he
really did
this guy was clutch he really was
obviously the home run
in the world series but more than that
class at
this guy and you have to appreciate the
red sox fans
i wish there was 30 000 here because
he'd really get it
he deserves it he really does
a little ground ball here snagged by
chavis up and over in plenty of time
with a baldy covering and nate pitches
around the ball four
take in that visual so the first time i
did it wasn't
staring down a behemoth in this red sox
lineup
so first strikeout for bassett tonight
he's in the top 10 in strikeouts in the
american league and here's christian
vasquez
bottom of the third from fenway park
ranchi cordero
michael chavis and then top of the order
marwin gonzalez
good fastball there i'm just gonna say a
guy that you need to go
and attack a guy that you need to get
the inning started off on the right foot
for you the runner in scoring position
for the first time tonight for the
athletics here's olson
this one grounded into right center
field a base hit
that's going to get brown home olson
comes through and we got a 1-1 game
that's exactly what you're looking to do
against a club like the red sox against
the guy
in iobaldi we talked about a little bit
of a mixed bag of results
last few turns but you're able to work a
lead off walk put some pressure on them
create a little bit of traffic on the
base path get your bopper up
chris looking for the shutdown ending
after the ace scored in the top of the
frame
and the offer breaking ball away
that a miss that was a pretty pitch and
a great reaction even
got a smile out of chris bassett seeing
bogarts wave through that one
back with the two-strike pitch best ball
away chased it
and he's gone on strikes nice job by
bassett since the single by verdugo
he's retired 11 in a row murphy the
catrice has some power
some think he's going to be a premier
defensive catcher
although he has thrown out runners as
lou mentioned earlier here it is
and he swings and misses at a breaking
ball a curve down and away to retire the
side
so we go to the bottom of the fifth
straight suit count now endeavors
christian vasquez is on deck
good fastball that one looked like it
had a little rise to it
well six strikeouts and kite your right
fastball like this up top is gonna hold
its plane
a little longer giving you that effect
like this ball is just
taking off envers seeing the same thing
wide open stance from the right side and
here's the one two by chris bassett tied
him up inside down he goes on strikes
so renfro swings and misses bassett
another one two three inning red sox
lone hit was
bordugo's single in the first inning and
he eventually
scored on a sacrifice fly so there just
has not been
a whole lot going on that one is driven
left center field nobody's gonna get it
and it bangs
off the green monster about halfway up
and cannon is going to have a sliding
double
this guy is firm all night long he's 96
plus all the time and a swing and a miss
he put him away
with the split two first place clubs
battling it out for the first of three
tonight at fenway
pounding ball up the middle gonzalez
crosses body
nice got him side retired still tied one
one one and two the count to
cordero swing you're gonna miss nasty
pitch
and that is eight strikeouts for bassett
one out here in the bottom of the sixth
right there and gonzales knew it that is
nine strikeouts for passing
darwin hernandez on in relief of nathan
avaldi who went six giving up
just two hits in one run hayes looking
to rally late here against the red sox
at fenway six it's 32 at bats with
runners in scoring position and that's a
base hit
so trotting into scores olson and the
ace take a 2-1 lead
how about the aggressiveness for the
green and gold on the base path that's
going to get that bullpin rattling
around for boston
and ottavino trying to shut the door in
this inning
so driven toward right renfro's gonna
watch it drop
in front of him and coming into scores
chapman
right off the end of the bat elvis will
take it and it's three to one acid has
retired
18 out of the last 19.
have a half swing massive grabs it flips
to first and the dangerous jd martinez
is out
swaying and a miss he struck him out he
came inside
and picks up his 10th strikeout in the
ball game a season high for him
here's rafael devers he is struck out
two times
season high 10. i fly ball into left
field
can of turning on it and that is out of
here there it is
that's gone home run for rafael devers
number nine
and the red sox get on the board for the
first time since the first
inning that's what he could do in fenway
park at any given time
any given time use that wall deekman
takes over it's his job to save it
he's trying to win another one-run game
pop-up this could do it murphy over
olson over it's gonna be olson foul
territory he grabs it
and that's the ball game